no threat why is what queen h6 and
there will be
this actually is losing eh but why what
why though be more constructive and so
on and so forth just
okay we're not threatening rook c2 yet
because we have a counter mate
we might be threatening knight c5 or
something yeah
so the point is if the rule goes
somewhere like h4 or b4 queen e5 check
just ends the game right that probably
is the
major major point
yeah that's a very very cute
construction
by this point the idea that most end
games
despite what you might be taught in
books are more or less pure calculation
it's also not a wrong idea as such
much of it is
just just absolutely being being able to
calculate well and and far
cleanly but
yeah visualizing this scenario that the
king might actually not might but will
get get out of the
the cage on g7 and then you just win the
pawn on g5 without having to
demonstrate any of the basic knowledges
very impressive
and pragnanda wins congratulations what
a
victory
showing great stamina great technique